[Music]
glad to have you here with us I will be
monitoring the chat closely right there
Truman and today I asked Ben Simon if we
could combine the classes of chess and
psychology and the intense insane
endgame I always get those two mixed up
so I could show you more in depth about
an endgame that I struggled with so
first of all I'm gonna continue look
look looking through and talking about
caro-kann for today so last week we had
more caro-kann and the week before that
we had some French and it's a nice
combination of those so I'm gonna
continue talking about French Baroque on
Pierre Philidor those of them throughout
the next few weeks of chess on
psychology and hopefully we will manage
to learn the openings and the concepts
behind it and get a nice idea of what to
look for in these openings so without
further ado so this is a nice game that
I had in Zurich Zurich Christmas open
2016 the rating of my opponent is
slightly wrong about 100 points less but
this was a very nice game and I really
enjoyed my time Zurich Switzerland is
one of my most favorite countries I
played there Bundesliga and our team
blonde and yeah I was at some point I
was actually considering living there
and switching my Federation to there so
there's that and so yeah this game is a
caro-kann game and I played with my
friend what I remember my opponents was
I think around 15 years old more
and he was a very nice player and
they're respectful and very gentleman
and everything and so I remember that I
don't remember having done much
preparation for this game because I it's
been years cuts from my memory I
couldn't find him or I there was little
time to prepare so I I liked that he
played caro-kann because I feel
confidence on this line with 99 a Street
even though it doesn't have that much
theory to its and also it's not that
tactical or that scary it's very nice to
be able to play something like that
because you know what you're doing and
if your opponent doesn't know what he's
doing and the goes a little off tracks
it things can get real Pleasant for you
real fast and that's something that
happened in this game so I'm gonna look
over chat and see if I have oh sorry I
have to try okay so I was wondering if
kind of anyone had any feelings negative
or positive is this 93 94 and caro-kann
so hopefully as soon as I get some
feedback I can show you a little bit
more all right
wow you guys are up and about in
different countries thank you
yeah there are some sacrifices on e6
there are some ones Bishop c4 that you
do that kind of sacrifices but kind of
the main idea like one of the main ideas
is that you kind of oops you want to
start pushing over here and kind of trap
this guy so one of the annoying things
to do for black or white is this e5
either here or after 97 because the idea
is if you take there's this check and
then after take the bishop is kind of
freed up so I liked that
and okay so there's so many different
lines there's 97 there's 96 but II six
is one of the most common ones and it's
the one that kind of makes sense to
everybody because you play a six because
you want to bring your bishop out pretty
early on you're not you're not rushing
into bringing Knights out or anything
but I feel like lots you either want to
play e5 so you set up for that or if you
want to put ecigs it doesn't really
matter how you do it feel free to
correct me if you have any other
suggestions okay so I remember that I
really like this c3 I looked at it a
while ago and this c3 is yeah that's
something that fragrance yeah that's
something that I considered like this c3
Queen c7 but there are this Queen f3 and
stuff it's very doable and I still have
my idea I do remember that there is a
deeper line that for example imagine I
start pushing and it there is this h6
there there is a line like this that
keeps going and going and that's very
that's quite I mean I like it this seems
pleasant for me oh thank you yeah I like
to test this stuff I try to match my
chest feelings right during this
difficult times the best I can do is
that please dress up nice alright so um
yeah well the the comment about my f3
well my tip 3 is the the most common and
then the main line and it has way more
Theory to it and way more in-depth 93 is
a little bit tricky and I like playing
that I guess it's just a matter of
preference
alright so I got to play my h4 and here
my opponents realize that well whoops
this h5 is coming
and he can't really play h6 because of
this one and she kind of decided to just
take on f4 because if not well what else
can you do let's say you just play a
little and this is not exactly how you
would want your caro-kann to turn out so
he decided to take on f4 and just play
solid h6 so if h5 now bishops can just
go back to h7 so here I'm pretty out of
theory I didn't really have much
knowledge in what to do after Bishop
takes f4 because well I it's a
comfortable position so I didn't feel
the need to analyze it that deep maybe I
should have but but it just felt like a
comfortable position so my first
question for you 71 viewers well how do
you want to proceed like as White's
where do you want your pieces to be
where they want your King to be just I
don't really need like a big line just
where do you want your pieces to be
let's see what you guys think
you're gonna do shorts castlelong castle
it's a little quiets all right good
Thank You sporting man yeah queen bee
tree so okay Nixon you want to play in
the center all right so if you all have
similar ideas you want to keep your
stuff happening in this Queen side and
center and yeah so queen bee tree
I'll clean the tree what do you think
black should do
ference yeah well you could play like c4
Queenie - but I kinda like this Queen b3
keeps it in Temple open and well my
opponent plays Queen b6 thank you I a 30
and yeah so my opponents after Queen b6
what do you think I should do as white
do you guys want to exchange Queens
maybe do you want to keep the Queen if
you want to keep the Queen where do you
want to place it
all right so don't exchange agree on
that um Bishop d6 not my most favorites
100 fragrance you're right it does look
awkward but it's kind of the best move
because after Queen a3 you have these
ideas to bring your bishop to better
diagonal you want to do long Castille
you might even have ideas to start
opening up the center so it's a very
pleasant position yeah
let's say Co 97 I kind of wanted to play
this h5 just so that I would push this
Bishop further a little bit more is I
don't feel like it's necessary but it
just it seems very pleasant and now I
was like well should I play long cast
though or is my King safe over here so
what do you guys want to do
long Casto short castle district t1
I don't like this day away I feel like
I'm sitting quiet for like seconds
waiting for still a but well they do
what we do with the on lines okay um so
you guys want to play a lot okay mainly
you want long Castille but Bishop e2 and
see what blacks doing I mean that's kind
of my style but I feel like okay so you
could try to play something like Kirk d1
first and wait and see what is your
opponent gonna do because okay so the
way I think about it black hands plays
shorts cast oh right so that's never
gonna happen so if I were to play a long
cast on you were to play a long cast uh
I can't I don't I mean the Weiss
position is still better but I can't
really start like a pawn March on you
because my own king is here so that's
why it might be a better idea to play
like rook t1 first and after a long cast
though just try to do short Castle it
seems a little weird
I agree but do you think this idea works
is there anything that whitey and the
black can do to make trouble for white
the way
for Peterson for Peter Peterson I mean I
saw it a little while ago but
okay yeah long hassle because I don't
think long castle had any problems
because of the bishop on h7 it was more
like if I did long casts on you did long
casts so then how would I attack you
it was more like dance
so what are we thinking
all right so you guys do you guys do
like this Bishop e2 on short castle idea
and if your answer is no well whatever
your answer is if you say no then what
do you think why it should have done if
you say yes then what do you think with
wax best move
oh my god you want to sacrifice Queen
well that's what be very nice okay so we
you guys are thinking about something
like e five I agree so do you think e
five okay so let's start thinking about
a five do you think it's a good move if
yes can someone give me a line like if
you five are you going to take it with
pawn with vision of what are you gonna
do
yeah I think you guys have the correct
idea so what you can do is yeah so
Bishop III is good
will you give Chad three good choices
like ABC I I would I'd like to do that
but I'm not sure how that would work so
it does look it with a little shaky
before white but you can easily take it
and after something like 95 what would
you do because you don't have much of a
tree anymore but what do you think is
White's best move
the problem with earlier Bishop III
would be same : the problem with earlier
Bishop III would have been probably same
95 and what are you gonna do with your
Bishop you kind of want that bishop to
stay and be part of this attack so after
take 95
what are your candidate news
oh well yeah that's a good idea John
Santa's you can't you can't I mean I
would really appreciate it if you guys
give me candidate moves or
full lines that would be really great so
like if you think if you're considering
what are one of the moves that you're
considering in this position just Rick
takes d5 or you wanna play with d2 or
some stuff like that
yeah I think this was also the good a
good mouth roof 65 I didn't play it in
the game I wish I have who would have
made a beautiful position but taking the
this would have been actually very nice
sacrifice because I think it's it's from
what I remember it was like clearer than
it is for white because now White has
super attack but the way I went about it
I just played and I am Bishop d2 and I
am going to continue pushing over here
shorts castle coming yeah it just it
seemed to be very pleasant I'm getting
another suggestion about rook takes d5
well Bishop e3 is nice but I feel like
it's more important to do short Castle
first to try and bring your pieces and
Bishop III is not going anywhere
so you shouldn't be in a rush to replace
your bishop also your bishop is super
strong over here so yeah alright so
Bishop d2 tonight takes e5 what do you
want to do
all right so I have a storage castle I
have a c4
let's see
all right so I went I like the idea see
four more just because it would clear
the road and it will move tonight a
little way
so now castle so now the question is who
do you think is better and if you say
white or black just try and give me a
move it is waxing over in this position
so what do you think who do you think is
better and what would you do yeah I I
saw the I'm looking at chat 90 trees it
could be problematic but I already took
care of it with c4
[Music]
so yeah I agree why it's better you have
two bishops and you're gonna go attack
the King
well it is why to move sorry it is black
summer so c5 is coming up but
okay so let's say queen a6 what do you
want to do now do you want to exchange
the Queens on half that better pawn
structure
yeah Quincy Street you guys are good
Queen C 3 very nice move and you are
still plotting this C 5 and look you
might be trying to trap the Queen
so after queen c3 let's say rook e8
so if c5 now cleaning can still move
around a little bit what would you do
after rook e8 you so one of the big
things in that most players struggle
with I still working on it is that you
like you see the position you know you
have advantage but what what should you
do with this advantage and that's one of
the big problems that most chess players
have the death converting advantage or
like finding the moves in position that
you know you're better so that's
something that's something that I would
recommend you guys working on as well so
for example in this position is white
you know you have advantage but how how
can you actually win this game so yeah
try and suggest few moves candidate
moves ideally and we'll go from there
[Music]
so I have a lot of B for suggestions b3
is nice you're being a little sneaky
with c5 nice a4 I like it I like Bishop
f4 most just because well it's putting
this bishop really does belong in this
diagonal so when you're putting that
Bishop on f4 and just pushing for that
diagonal it's it feels like a really
nice position on move
you might not know if you want to start
with me for a 4 or c5 but you know that
you do know that Bishop on D 2 belongs
on f4 so you might as well do that first
and then this island wishpond to push
and let's say Knight d7 now what do you
want to do so now your Bishop is where
you want it to be and it's about time to
start pushing puns which ones do you
want to start pushing thank you everyone
for for participating and suggesting
moves
I'm just getting way too much chat which
is great so I can't address every single
one of you but thank you for
participating I love it when the class
is interactive so yeah
just keep being interactive it'll be
great
okay so I'm getting pretty much
everyone's saying before we I have to
see flags on their stuff but I yeah good
I I really like this before - so after
before your ideas pretty clear right
you're gonna go for b5 and attack these
guys and so what do you think um Brian
would be one I'm not ready to start
sacrificing stuff so I I kind of like
keep my material and my attack so yeah
what do you think after b5 so those of
you who were thinking about b5 and those
of you who weren't what do you think of
black should do after b4
hmm well 8 I like taking on a - I don't
really think that's accurate move to
play Queen takes a - first of all what
do you do after something like work D -
like ok so what if you take over here
rookie - where do you want to go
anywhere you goes okay one is coming and
it's a little bye-bye Queen but yeah so
I think Dereham suggesting Queen a for I
think he was the first one who suggested
well yeah you all right it's Queen a4 is
the last try
now what again you see your position is
super good and you just don't you just
shouldn't rush pushing pawns and you
should keep preparing for it and so what
do you want to do do you want to start
pushing pawns is it is it time to start
pushing pawns or do you want to bring
more rooks or the bishop or so what do
you want to do
Misook f3 I do like the official web
stream
it's nothing by played in the game but
I'd really like it
also a little tip oh I saw John you're
right I was just about to give the tip
so the ones who were thinking about
delay that's the delay so you see how
horribly this Queen is placed here if
you could maybe you know attack it a
little then the Queen would be very
uncomfortable and it's almost Khans oh
right sorry 52 this is the idea block
isn't a bad shape you are right
so let's say black strives to do a
little bit more defense and like 94
so what do you do now and ideally give
me like a three move line or something
cuz the game is gonna be over in four or
five moves so it would be very nice if I
could get a full line out of you guys
oh that's a very good description up to
Aziz yeah you're right that's very
that's very nice advice so let's take
the night first and what now do you want
to start attacking the Queen or do you
wanna you know try and keep more pieces
around
yeah so okay Bishop d1 is a good move
but you don't want to rush it so you
kind of want to keep the dark squared
Bishop Brian you and right so maybe
let's keep the bishop a little bit and
then go for Bishop d1 because the Queen
can't really you know run away so I
don't think you are in a rush to try and
sacrifice stuff just try and keep as
many as pieces as you can but I do
believe Bishop do you on whoops bishop
d1 is winning enough so if you were
thinking about Bishop d1 and don't be
discouraged by this shove Bishop e3
Bishop e3 is just a little bit more
annoying and a little bit more precise
and my opponent just did something too
he didn't know what to do and I think I
mean b5 is very nice here but I just
decided to take more pawns and he just
resigned because this is extremely
uncomfortable oops
Bishop g4 coming everything is pretty
much falling and yeah so that's the
first game that I had for you guys about
caro-kann and I'm gonna switch to
another game is the night the only piece
holding blacks position together well
I'm in that position is super lost kind
of anyways so I don't think blacks
position is holding on it's just a
matter of few moves if no questions we
can go to the next game I wait to see I
don't have any questions
but yeah so while I'm waiting you see
this was a very clean win not just
because of the opening but because I
actually knew what I was doing I I could
I had the idea that even if my palm is
on edge five I can make short castle and
I knew the concepts of why I need this
Bishop to be on f4 I could I understood
that not to rush pushing pawns and I
worked very carefully to try and trap
the Queen and even though I didn't get
the Queen by the time he resigned I was
very comfortable with my position and my
ropes and everything was super active I
am drinking black tea I really really
like black tea
preferably our great Earl Grey but I
actually like this brand green field
it's really nice
I'm a big fan of it it's not that though
but I like it so Bryan you're still
considering the droopy one somewhere
where was it so around here you were
thinking of a syrupy one maybe
okay so Brooke b1 might be okay I don't
think that it's like a horrible move
then you're gonna lose but it's not the
cleanest way to win and if there is a
way a cleaner way and if there is a more
precise way to play I would advise you
to take that route rather than
sacrificing because I like sacrificing
you're automatically giving your
opponent a little bit more of a little
bit more to hope for basically or to try
and pull something off and it would just
the same way when you are you have more
material you feel like a little upper
hand it's the same thing what time is in
st. Louis 7:15 is p.m. okay so I'm gonna
go to the next
um ah there we go
okay so this was a a game against a
grandmaster from India Swapnil and he
was very strong and I played with him
in 2014 dubai open I want that game that
was a very good game I think I got my
first my second W I am in that
tournament but it's been years um and I
got like five or six W I am nervous by
the time I was submitting them they were
just like you so many worms so anyways
so but this was in Citrus tournaments in
2016 so fun fact I lived in Spain Oh in
2016 to 2017 from like July - July
before I moved to San Luis and I moved
there to play more tournaments and just
to get used to moving away from family
where my family could still come and
visit because it's kind of hard for
Iranian to get visit the US but to
Europe it was much easier and they
already had and so yeah it was a big
story and so while I was leaving that
here alone that was the year dies - 18
you're like a cheetah and I officially
got my titles that with GM and I am and
my fila trainer 1 so that was a that was
a nice year for me
2015 16 were my most favorite Chettiars
oh he is writing a book for Petrov Wow
great good to know yeah he's a very
strong chess player yeah all right so
this is another caro-kann I actually
sorry them I actually enjoyed playing
this a lot but I I got into little
trouble mmm
going from middle game to end game as
you guys you guys will see and
I managed to pull a draw as of the
opening so hopefully gonna be able to
show you yeah we were working on the
names thank you all right so so far
everything's similar to the last one
right uh just he also played the same
idea and I did slightly earlier age five
in this game I again did the Queen b3
and this time instead of Queen b6 that I
would get Queen a3 and this would be
very similar to the last game that we
saw that grandmaster played Knight d5 so
my first question for you guys is what
do you think you should do where do you
want the like it's not that well the for
this move is not that hard but just like
a brief idea
lunk a still short castle just something
like that left will you struggle to play
against -6 lines or wherein caro-kann
with 9 th Street
okay so you guys wanna take b7
[Music]
let's see okay so I'm getting a lot of
Bishop D choose some Bishop C ones and a
lot of short castle ideas yeah okay so
most of the once Thomas I agree on visit
T to so that's good and so once we
wanted to think about was okay so let's
say Queen c7 what do you do now there
was a question about the queen b7 so if
right now is play Queen b7 what I was
worried about during the game was with
you take and you put something like
Queen c7 my queen is gonna be a little
trapped
I just can't get it out and that's a
problem if you see a way to get the
Queen out let me know because I didn't
otherwise I would have taken the free
pawn so that's like Bishop d2 Queen c7
now as white what do you guys want to do
okay so
oh I'm getting some nice ideas on Bishop
a six alright we'll go back to that so
yes I like the idea of c4
long castle is too shaky to play and c4
is more convenient honestly okay sorry I
might have jumped on this a little too
fast so we said take take Queen c7 you
guys are suggesting something like
Bishop a6
what if Bishop a6 or Danny checks around
here
my d3 mmm not the biggest fan of 93
what about Bishop d3 Queen b7 hmm oh
hold on what about first Queen b6 so you
don't have to shove a6 anymore yeah so
that was in I was a little inaccurate
sorry for that Queen b6 should solve
this problem of fish with a six because
if you play Bishop basics now first of
all I have Bishop d3
second of all queen beaches are very
promising even maybe giving a check yeah
Queen B three Queen b6 is the accurate
one okay thank you for clarifying that
my eagle-eyed audience okay
so I Oh are you doctors from the SS the
white I forgot the username but are you
the Akash that plates me on twitch
channel the other day you've been a very
good audience very your presence every
time great so are we still thinking
about this Queen b6 or are we moving on
I'm just waiting to get the move on sign
yeah honestly Queen v6 is not that hard
to find Queen c7 seemed a little bit
more safe but Queen v6 is better just so
one way that you could think about
between Queen c7 or Queen b6 even if you
don't see Bishop a6 immediately is that
well you shouldn't ideally you should
it's good idea to have your pieces
protecting each other so don't leave
them hanging so clean on b6 is more
stable than Queen on c7 and that's why
it gives you the chance to play Bishop
d3 cuz if you were to play Queen c7
Bishop a6 Bishop d3 the Queen can run
away and your queen is under attack so
you don't have time to take this right
but if you play it Queen b6 and visual
basics you do have push up d3 Queen d7
doesn't work anymore because you just
take this guy right yeah all right
go out to clarify that up now thank you
from the moving gone sign okay so Bishop
b2 Queen c7 c4 Knight goes back to f6
now what do you want to do so we talked
about if you want to play short gasp
they're a long cast though where you
want to play
oh well glad to know you are the same
user and very nice of you to follow us
both on YouTube and the twitch well yeah
in the game that's we played I played
against Akash yesterday were the day
before that I've been here every day man
I'm losing time and so yeah well the
position well my position was pretty
lost anyways so that that one move
didn't make any difference and I'd
completely believe you you played very
well in that game you there's no need to
explain
we were just being funny but all right
back to this game oh yeah okay so Bishop
b4 I am a big fan of the move Bishop
before or Queen 83 those are the two
moves that I really liked and I think I
should have played but I didn't and I
play Bishop e2 so the way I think about
this right now is if I have played this
Bishop before or queen 83 either this
guy or this guy I would have prevented
you from black form playing castle right
so the way I think about it right now
this is these are the moves that I would
do today in my chest
immediately like I would that would be
my first choice
and then I would think about Bishop
issue but back in the day four years ago
well actually that was December not four
years ago three and a half years ago I
was still working on finding my style
and figuring out the moves that I like
and I allowed my opponents too much room
to breathe and I allowed cast oh I
shouldn't have done that I should have
played something like queen a tree or
bishop before I'm a bigger fan of Queen
a tree honestly but both of them seem
equally good to me they just share the
same purpose and I might want my I might
be able to get my Bishop back to come to
f4 but my Queen on a tree that's that's
good so yeah my recommendation is Queen
a3 to bow to me
for 2016 dorsa and to the 2020 audience
so yeah okay
so Bishop e2 Castle castle just normal
developments bringing the pizzas out so
I have one more question for you now we
are we've entered the middle game of the
middle game portion of this game so
where do you think your pieces belong
that's white do you like her clean over
there do you like her boobs what about
your Knights what about your rules so
just give me a little bit of geometry
and geography of where do you want your
pieces to be and
well Yuri
first of all it's never too late second
of all yes you I I don't think there's
anything stopping you to gain well
actually that there's a little bit of
problem stopping you because we don't
have any tournaments happening right now
sorry for that's a little dark joke but
you are fully capable of improving I
would have said just the studying
opening theories but I do think that you
could improve your first of all
calculation you need to be able to
calculate if you can't calculate you
keep blundering it's gonna be hard to
improve your chest so first one of the
big steps should be to be able to
calculate and blunder minimum minimum
and another thing I would advise is know
what you're doing it opening you don't
need to know every single move but you
should know what is the idea behind what
you're playing find comfortable setups
and that's what I've actually been
trying to do in this class to introduce
comfortable sets up so far for whites
and few few games I've shown for black
something again in nimzo-indian for
black and something in in Lopez for
black Irish on those and those are
comfortable you can try to look at the
other chairs on psychology classes that
we've had so you can get a good idea and
hopefully a few more months up here just
in psychology and I'll have a somewhat
of a full repertoire of just ideas but
you got to work more on itself alright
so back to this game I have good ideas
on drupe to have a look a to see one and
jerk f2d one and what do you want to do
with the bishop you want to put it on
III see three
yeah okay so Brooke c1 is what I went
about a5i I actually do you think I
didn't play f4 but f4 was a move that I
really thought about and maybe I would
have played something like that as well
if it was today so what do you think you
would do would you play f4 would you
move the F rook somewhere else anything
you want by a four why why do you think
you won't play it what's the personal
for black I had a question about how
calculates how many moves it really
depends on the position because it's
easier to calculate in endgame when
there are less pieces but I would say
try to do two three moves ahead two
moves ahead should be good enough so you
don't pull under stuff three moves ahead
would be good that you would be a step
up step above your opponent but it
really depends on that position if it's
positional and your or if it's all take
take take
so something about endgame knowledge
well anything knowledge is great but
it's really hard to actually understand
every single like theoretical endgame so
try to do practical and games and
understand the practical side of end
games so like in end games depending on
like know what you what to look for in
current games and try to turn to try to
know those I have good idea of like
Brooke hand games a little bit like what
to look for in the night one thing that
I was told to look for in like an end
game with nice is to be cautious for
example
like if my opponent has a night to be
careful not to put my king and like
other piece in like for King situation
so that was a good that was a good idea
another thing that I had was for example
but not in night and game it's a good
idea to think like think ahead like
where you want your Knights to be and
then find a way to get there it's like
if you want your Knights to be this part
of the board in there it's it's the
other part of the boards like just
figure out where you want it to be in
the new buds okay so we have ideas on f4
but f4 so my problem with f4 was 94 and
if you take take your Bishop got to
activate it and it's I don't know really
know what to do with my bishops so that
was my problem
Thank You Abdul Azeez for giving a align
and for all of you who are participating
in this yeah I wasn't comfortable
playing at 4:00 so yeah exactly because
efore makes it makes me for two week
Thank You one-two-three-four bunch of
fours
all right so I plan Turkey one just
because I honestly didn't know what to
do with my pieces I didn't know if I
once Riki 1 or d1 I didn't know if I
want Bishop f3 Bishop c3 and it was very
confusing for me so after this game I
went and I looked and I learned where I
want my pieces to be so that was that
was a good idea
[Music]
after route e8 i point Bishop d3 I think
rook t1 was doable something like Queen
f3 was doable and my problem with Queen
f3 was five and I just really really
didn't want to deal with this opening of
center and the Knights just attacking
and everything so what I did was Bishop
d3 and after exchanging the bishops off
I went and I exchanged it a little bit
more pieces off but there was a rook c3
here which was interesting because I
just I'm sure you guys heard me talk
about Turk on the 3rd rank all the time
but drunk on the 3rd rank is actually
interesting in this in this specific
situation because let's say you get few
moves to do whatever you want you can
move the Queen away and try to play
routine 3 you can try to relocate the
night you just have more ideas on what
to do what not to do anyways I went and
I played through Keef
94 take take Knight f6 so question what
do you want to do with your Queen
okay so I'm getting a queen as for idea
I'm having a queen e5 so it's pretty
much between these two so we're getting
yeah what's the woods 25 more 25
okay so I'm getting a lot of cleany
fives some Queen D 3 Queen f3 no because
I've Queen D for
okay so Akash problem with Queen e5 is
that it would go to the dark square the
pawn would becomes dark square and you
are right Queen h4 should be better
I played Queen e5 in the game because to
be completely honest I I was a little
intimidated by my opponent because he
was higher rated and a grandmaster and
all those and I wanted to exchange it
off but Queen h4 is what the opponent is
what the position needed and if it was
me today I would play Queen h4 let's say
rook d8 you take that pawn and this is a
very comfortable position to play or you
also have this idea with Bishop h6 24
I'm just Bishop here and then you pushed
upon it's a very very comfortable it's
more comfortable than what's happened in
the game so
after Queenie five what do you think
blacks best move is to take on e5 or
play something like the 58
okay so you guys want ripped it yeah I
agree Group C eight now do you see any
tactics for whites maybe and it's
anything to take anything interesting or
you just want to play Queen d6
okay so I'm getting some dishes age
sixes great black is equalizing and yeah
that that was my mistake the fact that I
gave blacks enough chances with 25 to
echo lies and develop and the default
that was my mistake
so Bishop f6 Queen d4 do you want to
take on d4 or do you want to play Queen
somewhere else
so the options are Queen d4 and I think
the other one would be probably Queen g5
because something like if you don't do
that your bishop on e6 is falling so if
it's black team if there's Queen e5
rookie five when you take the bishop
I think clean g3 the problem with Queen
coming to g3
is this Knight h5 possibly and would you
it's kind of hard to figure out what you
want to do with your pieces so Queen g5
is another possibility to consider so
Queen g5 black actually has a good move
that's a lob would be quite scary for
mine for me so what do you want to do
I'm not seeing it in the chat I'm seeing
lot of mighty force oh I see it good job
Scott
so queen g4 is what my opponent did in
the game but Bishop g4 is the good one
so Bishop g4 is what should have
happened sure having like problems
better great so yeah maybe think about
my g4 for a second and let me know if
you like that you prefer queen g4 yeah
what do you want
so wait nights clean up - uh anyways my
g4 is the best move for for black mainly
because the problem is what we want to
do with your pieces 96 is coming up and
[Music]
Queen if 2 is coming up and it's it's
kind of rough so I actually don't really
know what I would have done after 94 I'm
assuming probably something I can't even
play hold on what I what actually can I
do
god this is very unpleasant
I Bishop g7 doesn't work nothing like
cooking for worse diddly deee blonde
maybe rook t1 you take over here King
Ashwin
you can't take cause at night g7 maybe
rook e1 is what's good yeah I really
want seems to be the only one
rook cd1 so no checks
you can't take cuz I take this guy
so rookie for problem was queen d1 check
ya rookie I think book CD one kind of
holds everything together but black cos
is still better so I wouldn't recommend
that
cuz least of all there's queen of six
least of all
so like take King h1 Queen of sticks if
ya
I think this is why black would be
better
oh no you shouldn't resign you still
have moves to find ya Scott to your
rights okay so back to the game with
Queen g4 after queen g4 I kind of have
to exchange it off anyways and now my
bishop is under attack so let's try to
save this guy and now what would you do
with white so now we've entered the
endgame portion of our game and the
endgame portion of our class well black
is no black isn't upon up in this
position if Queen F - Queen f6 10-years
black would happen upon up
okay so I have some nice F trees some
Bishop H for some rookie force
well after is the one I played and f3 is
nice but it had some issues because f3
take take and you see the problem is
Brooke t2 what do you do you know okay
so practical aspects of endgame you
don't want your opponents to have drugs
on the second-ranked right you want to
have roofs on the second ring so that
was a big problem and my endgame started
to get a little them what's the right
word shaky-shaky
yeah so yeah
what do you think you should do you're
gonna take that pond or you're gonna try
and keep some stuff
not easy yeah
okay so I did taking the game okay so
let's look at this other move I thought
I thought King at seven so I remember in
the game I thought king of seven was the
more accurate like the person that I was
thinking what was king of seven but then
I realized I was thinking okay so asking
of seven I have rookie five and my other
rook is coming to give you a bunch of
checks and I can double up and
everything life is good for several key
aides I have this and this is good I
have so much pressure on your pawns and
I actually would have a slight advantage
and I thought if I can get six now I
double up again and I bring the King and
that's good I get my King to the center
right in time and yeah so that's what I
thought in the game but I forgot to
consider teach you more seriously
because I was like whoa who would give
up pawns but an endgame is if giving a
pawns means gaining more spatial and
activity advantaged and yeah that's
that's what you should consider
so after take Rock f8 this guy is coming
up what if what would you do is right
and to be fair white already is a little
bit of trouble so
yeah they would give our puns
whoa
did I click on oh sorry I clicks on
something but an accident we were right
after okay buddy
I apologize my lip
okay so I'm getting ideas I work with
one and pretty much everybody saying
okay flan I thought about your coupon
but I thought this is kind of really
really bad to play because I do think
this was the way I should have went
about it because now let's say if you
take over here I can take over here and
this is still doable and the good news
is your king is kind of stuck over here
and yeah does I think that's the way I
should have went about it but I I was a
little afraid and I just wanted to take
some material and see how it goes so
don't don't do that Senior Games if you
see a better defense dude ask
to be fair I do remember that I was in
time trouble as well so okay let's say I
put this is this is the way I went about
the game and this position is better for
my opponents and it it was very very
annoying for me and I just tried to
survive by so you see this nasty we
catch one whoops Lukesh one mate is
coming so I had to play King g1 he gave
a check I took bunch of pawns and then
he decided to try for this which he
rightfully did
and the problem is besides this King G
one King Shawn I don't really have
anything to do so whether if the juice
things connect 3nh pounds after yeah
that was one idea to try and take g5 and
see like pull something off of there
anyways
so this is the critical position my
opponents chose the wrong move which
gave me the opportunity to
save this game a little bit and so what
do you think blacks should do
ruk the g3 that was nice but yeah okay
so rights now what do you want to do
okay Yuri all right a4 is the best move
that wins the simplest way because a4 a3
a2 I just can't stop it and that's lost
Brooke Age struck h6 I didn't win the
game the game isn't a draw
rook h6 is what my opponents played and
which is not the most accurate one
a4 simply I just I just can't stop that
this is lost but after repair six I
actually got a little bit of chance to
breathe now I have some ideas to try and
maybe exchange the rooks up a little and
try and save the rook hands game and he
just tried to double it out the other
way now what do you what would you do is
white
keep in mind Rakesh one is coming up you
don't want to lose more pieces
ah wait why are you guys saying your k1i
money a little behind in the lack of
ruckawhat ruckas 100 false no rooks III
it's still the same problem Brooks III
so if you were to poops Playworks III
what would you do after
check-check maybe a little bit more
check oh no see five so that's good
because if there were see if there was
see five then you had to take with the
King and whoops you give up the rook
rook c3 is possible but there is
something more accurate rook F 1 is the
easiest way and so rook F 1 rook each
one King up so if you were to take take
and v6 this is again advantage for black
it's harder to win compared to that a
four line but it's winnable however
giving check and then check and then
again another check whoops I am sorry I
don't know why
oh I keep not slipping over here sorry
and so after eventually she took on the
rook and after I took the other rook
now let's like let's think about this
endgame
so what do you guys think is this ant
game winning is this lost
okay so well Black has more chances to
win but Black has advantage but it's not
enough to win the wall I mean we both
played a little inaccurate and yeah okay
so glad to know everybody is loves
endian so much okay
so let's say Luke a1 would have been
slightly more accurate because let's say
Ricky five and you get to push faster
but then it would give me the chance to
like lock those up so I think that's why
he didn't like the idea of getting that
c5 to lock the beef he didn't like the
idea of this c5 and locking these guys
up and I think that's why he played
rooks e1 going toward c4 look at four I
think it's the same idea but if rook F
four I would have had c5 again or maybe
just taking and taking on g4 and now I
have c5 and that is a draw fun fact I
actually want something like this with
black oh I wish I had that's ready to
show but thank you but I don't that's
yeah I'll I'll include that in the
another series because that was a nice
end game but okay to be fair the end
game theoretically is draw and my
opponents played quite inaccurate hi
everybody hi to Jason oh great okay so a
let's say York c1
rook takes a four a five or six c4 okay
so I'm gonna test your knowledge of rook
and games a little bit what do you what
do you guys think is the theory
theoretical results behind this is this
winning for a black because this can
White's saved this a little bit
yeah you want to have a beep on only ok
so oh gosh I do have a queen ends game
but I I don't think it's would be able
to cover all of it I will dedicate the
next one to only clean and clean and
clean versus true cam games because I
did actually lose a game like that with
when I had the rook so the answer to our
crash I do have a queen ends game ready
but I don't like if I'm showing the damn
game that you asked me I kind of want to
cover more of it just in instead of just
the third-ranked so I am working on it
still ok so you gotta bring the King
activate that guy keep activating it so
far everything as long as you can right
you are the other thing is you kind of
want to have this truck you know kind of
behind so it's better to go the other
way with a check ideally so let's say it
can have six now you get to play rip g8
but my opponents are smart enough and he
played king of seven I tried my best to
try and get my rook there a little and I
tried to give a little bit more checks
so now I do have this true kf8 but I if
I play let's say Rock f8 I give you the
chance to bring your king very easily so
I wanted to avoid that on half that King
cut another good another good example to
try and do as practical an end game
specially with trucks is to cut the king
always try your best to cut the king I
actually do have an example to show her
to show for an end game that I I forgot
to cut the king and things gods really
messy real fast so but in this game I
remember and then I cut the king let's
say King edge 5 and so what do you guys
think truck t5 is do you think rocket if
I was good
going through that spawn ins game do
think English 5 is a wrong idea
yes James caught the king of good so the
one of the most important things to know
in end games is you gotta know your
opponent games because when you know
your part because most end games have
the chance to just exchange everything
off and get to the pawn in the game so
if you know your opponent's games you
have the ability to calculate and be
like okay so if that part of the game is
losing I don't want to get to that part
of the game so I wouldn't play something
like King gets five so and a good
reference that I did on permanent games
was the last sometime in January when
Tata still was happening I think I did a
game I analyzed the game theorists jaw
versus kiri
and that was a very beautiful end game
so hopefully you guys can go and look at
look that up it's in the same channel
saying YouTube and it should be very
easy to look up that was a very
beautifully done end game and he won an
aquarium the theorists repeat and Gary
mainly because he knew what he was doing
an end game and that he was very
comfortable knowing his opponent games
on everything okay so Rick t5 I kind of
have to take and after take I I can't
survive this with white because of King
h6 according to what I checked cuz my
pawn gets to be a queen with check and
it's it's survivable because you if you
play something like King these six
blunder I come over here if you play
something like King f6i again have check
and I can go after this guy what else if
you play kinky seven same idea if you
play King a five again same idea if you
play King f5 I have queen of seven so
pretty much I'm going after this pawn
and I this seems to be doable or
perpetual like because I see that I'm
going to make a queen with check I can
assume that there are more possibilities
if I made a queen without to check
alright so now it's a little it's a
little sketchy yeah I wish I could ask
our boss
okay so rook t5 doesn't work and my
opponent correctly sides and so rook t1
after rook t1 what I could do thank you
very thoughtful Tracey was to try oh I
don't want to give this move up
okay I have a question about the
previous that we were analyzing so after
King age six well king of seven the
problem is again King gage six and then
I will make check again I also give you
a check along the way and if you play
something like king of sex I have King
age six and I again will give you this
check and now I will Queen before you
which I again pick up that pawn push
push and again by by pawn does that
answer the question
oh no we want skin gage six because we
want to we want this King gage six this
page six is a good square we want King H
six because King is close enough to help
you push the pun and if you play King g6
you're kind of blocking your own pawn so
don't do that
okay everybody good on this hand game
cool
rook t1 so will what do you want to do
with white
okay
so remember how we talked about cutting
King and everything
another great concept to be aware of is
having your rook behind your pawn so
ideally I would want this rook to be
somewhere behind here to protect my pawn
right so at this point I have to decide
between am I gonna keep cutting the king
or am I gonna bring the rook away and
push the pond and I can't really start
pushing the pawn if my rook is on the
way and it's gonna be attacked by the
king so that's why I brought the rook
back b5 g5 and it's a nice pond race I
do think that's playing something like
group c2 would have also been
interesting because now King d5 and now
I can start pushing
I got your King a little away from the
scene so let's see if there are going to
be any differences between now g5 or g5
after-work c2 so Brooke c1 rook f6 King
up and a bunch of checks and then you
push and you get the pond or if King
goes to c3 you have route to g4 so keep
this idea in mind and we are gonna use
this in the real game because my
opponent didn't play rook she want my
opponents blade rakesh won't check first
so this position we just looked at rook
to you online squats rook h1 is the line
that my opponent played and we will look
at it again so the problematic g1 was
that Andrew G for remember to keep bunch
of checks you keep you push the king to
go away and you bring your rook to cut
the rook or you get that pawn either one
works to get the drop so
Ruka chuan now let's say King g6 now
Brooke Jiwon is safe now right because
that's route can't really go to g4
anymore remember that position that they
would push and we'll put the Rick to g4
basically this position I don't have
that chance anymore so roof g1 is good
well they're low there are a lot of
little traps the rooks j4 was a little
trap on my opponents knew it so he
avoided it
okay I'm gonna pushed a little faster
over here so I gave some check to free
my king so start pushing
pushed a little g7 now this position
theoretically is a draw regardless of
how my opponents will continue but I
would like to get some inputs on what do
you think or your you would do as black
would you keep pushing pawns with you
bring the king would you just take that
pawn oh these are interesting but almost
done come on that crash stay with us a
little bit longer
ah Thank You a scotch and thank you
everyone who are writing just a lot of
names can't really go although can't
really cover everything sorry but I
appreciate your comments okay so let's
look at Brooke g7 so he my opponent in
the game to cook g7 and I would like you
guys to even though I've told you that
this game is a draw maybe take it a
little bit and actually calculate it
because that's like this is the final
trick
so fun fact while you guys are thinking
I I've talked about this 26,000 and came
studies that I I've been doing and so
one this position is actually one of
them I remembered in that game that I've
seen this position somewhere but I've
never played it so I was just like where
have I seen this I knew this was a draw
but I just couldn't point out like
exactly what are the moves and I was so
pissed that they came that I couldn't
remember the moves of the puzzle and
this is the puzzle so I'm gonna look at
Kings d4 first because window King he
took g7 so we'll get to that right after
so King deform the move to play is rook
be to the idea is that I want your Kings
to come to c4 so it blocks your pawn on
c6 so that this pawn can't really go as
easy and now the camera move is rupee
one if you take it oops
if you well no no no we don't want to
catch one we want this guy there you if
that happens then I just have the Queen
correct there is a trick you see Rick do
you want
look b1 was a trick if you don't know
rugby one you can of course you can
think about it in the game but this was
a trick if you don't know it again if
you don't know it you can logically
figure it out so you'd be like okay Pete
you I'm gonna play with your king all at
all and then drop be one but you have to
think about your p1 and let's say Kirk
goes away a little bit not check and you
come to c3 and now this is a draw
because you your rook is like the
Maverick and just to point out if there
was king c3 this is even easier b1 let's
say you move wherever and you get this
guy and now
this is also a draw because I'll just
come take this guy and you take that guy
in wala so that's why I can't see for is
the move that was accurate through p133
and this is a draw even if rooks see to
for example I give the check again and
come here attack you if you push I come
here and I just take this
this was the theoretical wine asking
before custody six point false so if
teaching before I just take over here
and I give you check and I take this
class whoops can't take this I am
fighting for a draw so taking that
though your last remaining pawns aren't
good enough okay yeah kind of metric
right okay this is not what happened in
the game but this was this would have
been really great
I could actually submit it to places to
win something I'm kidding
it's already a puzzle okay so let's say
Group g7 like my opponent did in the
game we're just I don't kind of made my
life a little easier because laughter
take C five all I have to do is try and
bring my king right in time and keep
these pawns from becoming Queens which
is again all I have to do super easy
right anyways rook e8 good idea to put
your work behind the pawns c4 fruit b8
so the idea was recreate is that now if
c3 your pawn is falling so I I'm
stopping you a little from pushing so
fast so now that you move your king I'm
bringing my king if let's say King C
tree I have King g5 I'm bringing my king
and I take this and I go over here and
if King be one again with p3 see very
nice too little like who just roof right
on time right okay so if King after king
f6 we just looked at king c3 that I
brought the King and I got to the pawns
right in time
and if you push the pond what do you
think you should do because it's per its
cup pretty much the last question in
this game so suggestions comments
the endgame by pretty exciting huh you
always think route can games are boring
and you end up it's such high nice
examples of rookie one and stuff like
that huh
yes you are right you do have to give
the check because if you take first the
problem is the classic at the end King
c8 fragrance here correct rook before
the pond is poisoned because of that end
King c8 so it's good to know your end
games and the thing is if you don't know
them you can't actually think about them
and figure them out but it's a good idea
to have solve puzzle so you know what to
look for so that's why work before is
better and you come over here I just
take this and we agreed on the draw so
yeah I hope you guys enjoyed this one I
have um we still have a bit of time and
I would like to give you some puzzles on
in end games hopefully like a little
tactical so we could go over those and
you guys could enjoy trying to apply
yourselves so um just give me one second
to pull that up find it first
nice let me make sure oh this is a nice
one
okay let's look at this it's White's to
move what do you guys want to do
oh yeah so okay so guys full line is
your first movie eight making night
I see a lot of promotes two nights but
give me full line
mm-hmm
if you do need your Bishop f6 Bishop f6
is forced mate
because if you were to play eh well
Queen you get kind of mated over here
just a little bit sometime soon yeah
there we go and if you played the night
if you played nice checking and go to it
can run away but if you play this and
you make night now it's me yeah okay so
let me load the next one while you guys
are still looking at this one oh this is
a good one this one is black see
for the last one if you guys are still
debating and there's on you guys are not
clear the best move was Bishop f6 first
check
so I see
I'm saying okay are they still
confusions I think I should go back to
the last one okay so you guys are gonna
go southern chat great you're doing my
work for me perfect but yeah so the
answer to if bishop in the last one
sorry you guys are still talking about
it
this position is black to move the last
position after Bishop of six in King if
King tried to run away you just take the
rook free work this one is black so move
so the little trick to know who's to
move it is is usually when I load the
position if there is the look at this
rank if this is eight then it's black to
move if this is white then it's white to
move so if that if this rank is eight
it's black to move if the rank that you
see first down here is one then it's
white to move
I don't smell Russian off of it so I
can't pronounce that but you are kind of
correct that's one of them but no not
yet Easter is not the first move
so can someone tell me what is wrong
with a straight first
be careful the drew h2 because of my h2
and you don't really have the much more
checks left
so h3 is a little slow because of nice
g3 and the first one is not a check your
rights
this is a good thing right it's getting
you guys thinking
I'm still not saying to move ah this is
so nice I like it when I give puzzles
and um takes a good while with this good
puzzle right um nope I'm still not
seeing the move okay so big tip first
move is not a pawn move nor it's a check
that should eliminates a lot of the lot
of the moves right so not a pawn move
and not a check
oh I see it okay so uh Peter cross
rookie won you have to play rookie one
first
sorry guys I have to give it up but it's
I also had then lit storm say it so and
luan okay yeah
so rookie one is the rights move it's
pretty cool huh
if you make this Queen h3 wins if you
make the other Queen h3 again wins so
I'm gonna give you guys the seconds to
ask me questions
hmm anyone questions comments shocked
faces
so I think the the biggest thing is that
it's kind of unorthodox to play stuff
like that but the problem is that in
this position you can't like that's
pretty much the cleanest way to try and
push the pawns because if you push now
this is the problem and you don't want
to start pushing because then there
there's so many you create so many holes
so that's why you play tricky one to
kind of keep this Knight intact so next
you can play h3 that was actually they
played the chind real game I I can only
hope I would see this in the real game
well yeah it's a nice trick right
alright so give me a second while you
guys still thar disgusting this so I
look up the next one I want to find
something cool again
whoa why so loud just hold on
give me one more second okay this one is
kind of cool this one is white to move
it's not as cool as the other one but
still
what do you guys want to do
oh yeah we need to find this Igor Ivanov
schemes you're right you're gonna get
right on that
I think for this puzzle we have a winner
LuAnn was the first one yeah good puzzle
huh I'm gonna give it a few more seconds
before I show it on the board
but yeah look at five is the best move
whoa yeah we're cat5 the problem idea is
you kind of have to take it and I give
you another check and mate nice huh kind
of nice
no we're near the last one right all
right give me another second to find a
good one
I have I wish I had them in order I was
planning on doing another puzzles but
this is these are pretty cool too
hopefully these will keep you guys happy
and we've done this before this one was
a good one nope oh all right
found it okay what do we think about
this and this was actually a game that's
mean cautionary and Karpov and 17:8 try
think was there a rule championship in
78
oh okay so just a little bit oh my god
ha
yeah this isn't in the I blog bloody you
I can't say it's for life of me city
this so this was this this was the the
world championship match
all right so I'm getting a lot of
responses thank you everyone
what do you think okay thank you I'll
crush for giving me a full line and
everyone else who did not after EGF tree
if you go away this is just cute mate
Knight f3 take you take I give the check
and another cute mates right alright
let's go to the next one I had it's
ready I closed it okay there we go
hopefully it's okay
this is also a game of Petrosyan with
white in 1979 hood f-cove I don't
believe this was a World Championship
match but
yeah you guys are right the last time
Knight f3 was the pretty cool huh
again nothing you I don't think any of
these moves will ever top that's rookie
one but yes it is way too
oh thank you I'm getting a lot of tea
for rookie fives great pastry mates f3
mates yeah
thank you James Pratt's for the
clarification as well okay let's do one
last one
I need another second to find it cuz
okay
yep this is also a pretty cool one this
one is why to move
Oh Arthur thank you um I believe that
their truth there's one way to do it in
YouTube and there is another way to do
it in twitch maybe Bensimon can help
with our tours question okay
oh the dollar sign and the YouTube
doesn't seem to work well there is
another I did I do know that there's a
nice pool of donations going on the
twitch channel that we're doing for an
elementary school and it would be pretty
cool to try and get to our goal and I
made a very regrettable announcement
that's when we hit 75% I will sing on
stream so there's that
Tracy's laughing right now okay great we
have we have some nice moves
yeah so ruk a5 is the cool the cool way
to win this game pretty much oh thank
you Nixon pretty much after okay five
the idea is when you take now you have
this cool Bishop c5 and rocketry coming
up
see cool right so for those of you who
it's a little harder to see route k5
immediately it's very easy to try and
train yourself into thinking how how to
make this candidate moves and the best
way to do it is to train yourself to
first think about checks all the time so
if you're in this position thinking
about checks the checks you're thinking
is route p66 route k5 and you're like
none of these are really pleasant
because looks between 66 and rook p6
because you're kind of just letting the
king run away but route 85 is
interesting because you get the chance
to bring the king more in the corner and
more exposed and that's why you are
thinking about your k5 so that's how you
can try to think about your ok 5 and get
then train yourself to just see it
faster than usual just try to think
about checks immediately like whenever
whenever you're looking at the position
just to have them in the back of your
mind like ok so these are the checks
possible checks possible takes and even
if they are kind of a weird text or
unreasonable or kind of just you don't
want to do it still think about them
have in the back of your mind like rook
a5 might seem a little weird at first
but that's the best that's the best way
to go about it and then now keep finding
Bishop c5 you should think about it's
like okay so this chick doesn't work the
king just goes away
this chick doesn't work because the
problem is king can just run away and in
order to have the King stock and not to
make the King run away you should this
is the score that the king wants to run
away from it so you bring your bishop
and take this a squared away that's the
simplest way to think about it and you
bring it
and you keep it keep the king over here
so the pond is whoops the pond whoops
the pond is keeping this square the
bishop is keeping these squares and
droops coming for me I do think that's
the move a four is also possible because
you are you still have that chance of
mating and if you take its mates but
it's tit it's not clean and hold on what
do you do after rookie seven never mind
a [ __ ] is not possible technical glitch
a four is nice if the opponent takes it
but even if a four would miraculously
work and you could do some check and
actually when you shouldn't really try
to do that because Bishop c5 is the
cleaner way to win so that is my
recommendation and all right I am glad
you guys joined us for two full hours
that was very nice I am very glad to
have had hundreds plus for yours I do
have one last question do you ever find
the chest after chess school you try to
put the ideas into practice yeah of
course like when you're trying to to do
the ideas yourself it's still kind of
hard to try and achieve it but the more
you practice and the more you like ask
yourself questions so the big thing that
works for me when I'm playing is to ask
myself questions like what does my
opponents war I want
what does if it's my opponent to move
what am I do like what does he want to
do how can I block it so what like just
asking myself questions and that helps
me a lot in my games and just solving
puzzles and everything hope I hope that
helps and yeah well tune in for
tomorrow's the streams and classes I'll
be back for teaching on Thursday we have
another a lot of things set up for
Thursday there's ladies night there's
ladies play the people there is um oh
there is a game of games of the week
both there's internal games actually
being played this week or the board so
can't really do that but I'll come up
with a good game to show you guys and
yeah so tune in we have stuff happening
in the club every day either in twitch
channel or YouTube and thank you again
for staying with me for 2 full hours
have a good rest of your day
[Music]
you